hi well I think it's not the case
um Maria de gardaver who is the
spokeswoman for the foreign Ministry who
is with Sergey lavrov in Indonesia has
said that it's not true
um she's with him now she they're
reading the wire they can't believe
their eyes and there's a video that
she's just posted where you can see the
foreign minister sitting in his shorts
working on the on the balcony and she
says to him
um you know what do you make of these
reports that you're ill and he says well
they say that our president is ill too
and that that's not true
um and that Western journalists should
be more honest and tell the truth so I
think
um the original newswire that this came
from that said that uh lavrov had been
sent to hospital on heart condition
cited uh Indonesian officials
um but uh it it clearly turns out to be
not the case I mean this video is pretty
pretty demonstrative uh you know he he
says I'm I'm sitting here I'm fine uh
I'm not in hospital he's clearly not in
hospital so I'm not really sure where
this original reporting came from but it
would appear that it's not true
um just tell us why he's gone to
Indonesia
he's there for the G20 in place of
Vladimir Putin who decided not to attend
in person himself really because I think
uh the Optics of him being snubbed on
the world stage would not have been good
um and uh you know just as his generals
took the Flack really for uh having to
make the announcement on the withdrawal
from Kirsten so his foreign minister is
going to have to take a slack
politically for what Russia is doing in
Ukraine I think that's why Sergey lavrov
has gone it'll be interesting to see who
he actually has meetings with
um uh Rishi sunak knows if he will come
face to face with him at some point I
doubt that there'll be any kind of a
bilateral
um but has said that he will make
Britain's position very clear
um and we shall see how you know the
rest of the G20 leaders respond to him
but I think already there has been
discussion that there won't be a group
photo at the end of The Summit because
they don't want to be
um photographed together with uh the
Russian foreign minister and there also
won't be a group communique because
presumed blue Russia won't sign up to
anything that the rest of the g19
um you know that put down on paper so
it'll be a very fraught Summit I would
imagine where Sergey lavrov will be
fairly isolated
um but where the war in Ukraine will be
Center Stage